thanks everyone for for being here so I
would rather people stop me and ask lots
of questions then get through the
content I have here so please feel free
to stop and ask questions at any point
I'm gonna in particular talk about one
sub area of research that I think about
but also something that's been getting a
lot of media attention in the last
couple of years which is to say machine
learning and sort of how well or well it
does not work in a variety of specific
applications okay so you all are
spending some time in the Bay Area so
you've probably heard pitches about
machine learning being used in almost
any domain you can possibly imagine so
you know machine learning is is being
pitched as sort of the magic the magic
beans of all sorts of different things
you know there are people who are saying
that we'll be able to predict wine
quality quite well and I'm sure there
there are startups which are trying to
do things like this or try to predict
your taste in wine based on your prior
desires in terms of wine there are lots
of examples of sort of more silly
applications these don't look so good on
the slide but generating pictures of
cats like little silly cartoon pictures
of cats as well as in many cases looking
at how well one can either much smaller
on this than I remember
looking at how to personalize a
customer's experience when interacting
with some company right there's also
lots of people who are hoping to use
machine learning to do a better job
pricing anything you can imagine for
example a secondhand cars right so I
give this as an example because we've
been selling secondhand cars for a long
time and at least some fraction of the
population thinks we know how to do that
and yet there are people who think it
can be done more efficiently or machine
learning methods this is one of my
favorites
so someone has decided it would be
humorous to try to use basic machine
learning methods to try to from images
of marijuana plants predict which of
them are going to get sick with common
diseases for those I can't I can't
attest to the veracity of any of any of
their results or how they came to them
sorry sorry so I was asked whether the
people who were considering machine
learning for such cases were inebriated
in some way and I'm not sure if I'm not
sure if that's the case so one might
think this would be a bit of an overkill
in terms of an example where one might
want to use machine learning but
recently as in like within the last year
Microsoft announced that they'd be using
machine learning to try to predict when
they should offer updates to their
software so as to not annoy the user of
the system right so rather than that
popping up while you're making some kind
of presentation and you having to click
on the thing they thought machine
learning would be like a more
appropriate way to predict whether
someone was actively using their system
or not you might say that's a bit of
overkill right there are other things
one could do lots of medical groups are
hoping that AI and various forms of
machine learning will help them do a
better job in terms of all kinds of
patient care right both in terms of
medical studies but then also in terms
of you know the way actual caregivers
interact with actual patients right
there's also the tacit hope that machine
learning methods will be more objective
when it comes to doing all sorts of
different tasks than humans making those
same sorts of choices there are any
number of startups that are employing
machine learning to sift through large
numbers of
for both low and high skilled workers
and the hope in each of these cases if
not the you know second or third line of
those pitches is that a I could actually
do a better job reducing the bias in
terms of the machine learning in terms
of the people one brings in for an
interview okay I have many other
examples right this is just yeah so yeah
you know many examples so you know it's
true that like machines might do a
better job processing certain kinds of
images than human eyes they have the
capacity for actually doing a lot more
processing on on pixels yeah people have
also thought about sort of whether
machine learning can do a better job
pricing real estate and any other
possible thing you could possibly
imagine right um I have a few others
okay on the other hand simultaneous in
the last like five or so years to this
really explosive adoption of machine
learning technologies in almost any
domain you can imagine have been a bunch
of examples which you guys have probably
heard at least to some extent about
right so one example is so you all
presumably know that Google matches our
ads tries to personalize them based on
all sorts of information they have about
us and based on the Preferences of
advertisers right but it does some
non-trivial matching often based on
statistical information and a number of
different things have been found that
may be considered problematic for
example there's some recent work that
has shown that lots of high paying job
advertisements are much more likely to
be shown to profiles that are considered
male as opposed to people female there's
now mounting evidence that any number of
pieces of statistical software which are
being used in the criminal justice space
as broadly as one could imagine
work have different levels of predictive
power for different demographic groups
right so this is just a screenshot of
one part of a Pro Publica article about
a specific example of this one let's
rather contentious but you know from
policing to sentencing to bail decisions
and all sorts of risk management systems
there are definite questions as to the
veracity of the claims that are being
made by the companies who are making
this kind of software so this will come
up again later in the talk I think if we
get there but one of the earlier fun
things that Google was doing with a huge
number of images that it had uploaded it
had access to and crawling the web was
trying to auto tag them with all sorts
of things about the subjects in those in
those images and I'll show you the
example much later for a different
reason but there was one young woman who
was who noticed that images of herself
and her friends were being labeled as
gorillas and that's particularly
problematic given that these people were
african-american it's not great and it
would be a mistake if we were labeling
any images of humans gorillas because
that's an error but there's an
additional social cost when that comes
when one's actually thinking about the
historical basis for such behavior okay
I won't just drag on one large tech
company Amazon was using some you know
secret in-house machine learning model
to try to guess who would be the top AI
talents to try to hire and it was doing
a much worse job predicting the quality
of research for women than for men and
you know there are many many many other
examples but I'll maybe give you a few
more that are not
so tech focused right so as I mentioned
one of the places in which people are
thinking about machine learning really
improving our day-to-day lives as
opposed to our online online lives is
this idea that like medicine and our
medical care providers could use tools
developed with statistics involved to
give better care to our patients right
and there's preliminary evidence that we
may see problems as a result of that
right so we already have a lot of
evidence ignoring machine learning
systems in general the quality of care
varies wildly when you look at different
demographic groups rich why men tend to
get the best care out of the US medical
system compared to anyone else and we
seem to be seeing similar results when
it comes to looking at ML methods that
are based on any number of different
kinds of historical pieces of data
there's I think part of the problem and
part of the real concern is that so much
of the machine learning that people are
doing and saying we'll fix things is in
general thought of as very blackbox and
very proprietary and it's not in general
right when a large company spends a lot
of money investing in some kind of
machine learning system they don't in
general want to be very open about how
it works why it works the data it was
trained upon they don't in general want
to yeah
so so right so the the comment the
comment here is am i doing the right
thing right right and in Ghent right
right right
so it's certainly the case that if if
you are a collection of people you're
most likely to produce some some
software or artifact in general that
represents the values that you as a
group already already exhibit right
and that certainly either explicitly or
tacitly the case and a lot of these
[Music]
that's not clear I'll say a little bit
more about that yeah yeah so the
question was I think let me rephrase and
see if you're happy with my rephrasing
you know machine learning systems in
general look at trends they find in
their training data and then try to make
predictions based on the trends they
find in that training data and while
that is true it is not entirely clear
that all of the behavior we're seeing
here is entirely the result of trends we
see in the data that is almost certainly
part of the problem in some of these
cases but that's also sort of it's not
looking at all of the possible sources
of this kind of behavior yeah so you
know there are many many other examples
this is one of my favorites
it was it was in the news not not too
too long ago we're so so to poke fun
again at one of the one of the large
tech companies Amazon's facial
recognition system when run on the head
shots of the members of Congress had a
huge number of false positives when
matching the facial shots of members of
Congress to their criminal database sure
but like different people right so there
were a huge number of false positives
and the number of false positives
amongst Congress people of color was
nearly twice the rate it should have
been compared to the rate of false
positives of Caucasian Congress people
okay and the ACLU did this study right
and that seems to be somewhat
problematic you know we could go on and
on there's there's another example where
you know if you're using machine
learning to do something like predict
skin cancer you should make sure that
you have a pretty representative sample
of people with different types of skin
there are lots of examples where if you
don't you will have some problems in
terms of your predictive power yeah so
one final thing which I you know briefly
mentioned before there are a lot of
people who really want to use histories
of arrests as like recent histories of
arrests as a strong indicator that one
should send future future limited police
resources into a neighborhood right so
if what you say is I know that we
arrested a bunch of people for crime X
in this location that means that we
should send more police into that
location to look for crime X and maybe
other crimes as well there are all sorts
of problems that come from systems that
work that way especially given that we
don't arrest people for the same sorts
of crimes and equal rates in different
communities
right and that can lead to the idea you
know drug use illicit drug use is
roughly equal across across different
demographic groups conditioned on
socioeconomic status right five percent
but the rate at which we we put people
in prison for it is very very much not
evenly distributed okay so if we then
use where we arrested people for for
those particular crimes as justification
to going into those neighborhoods and
sending additional police to look for
more crime we may never find the crime
in other neighborhoods which may be
happening at the same or even greater
rates okay okay so that is to say you
know we we have some explaining to do we
as like people who are sellers or or
people who are encouraging the adoption
of machine learning and I think the
short answer to why we might be seeing
some of this behavior is that we don't
know how many of these machine learning
systems work we as like users as opposed
to the producers but that also extends
in many cases to the people who are
actually developing these machine
learning models it's not at all clear
that in a lot of these cases they
expected the behavior that is being
pointed out right and there is mounting
evidence that some of these systems as I
mentioned have very different predictive
quality for different demographic groups
and as Dennis alluded to a moment ago
it's not entirely clear why I mean there
is at least one answer that maybe at
least sometimes responsible but it's not
clear if this is the results of the
choice of algorithms we're using to
optimize or whether it's the result of
the choice of models were optimizing
over right so maybe we're using linear
models which are a perfect predictor
based on the set of features we have for
some populations but somehow that we
really needed you know we needed
something slightly different for a
different demographic
it's not clear if this is an
inevitability due to differences in the
distributions over the set of features
we have for different demographic groups
right if we are going to allow ourselves
to use machine learning in these
particular contexts it's not clear if
this is the result of you know if you
take a random sample of the United
States and it was perfectly
representative we would still have more
people of certain demographic groups
than others which means we have more
statistical power to talk about the
larger groups than the smaller groups
for anything we learn from that data set
and it's not clear if what we're seeing
is primarily the result of having far
more uncertainty about smaller
populations right one of the things that
people speak about a lot is stakeholders
and who's in the room when they're
making decisions about what kind of
models to use right so if you walk into
any of these tech firms you're not going
to see a representative slice of the
American population nor will you see
them gathering data in Iowa or Louisiana
they'll be driving cars to look for look
for data outside of Stanford yeah could
be yeah yeah yes so so the the point was
if we're developing a model in Palo Alto
it's not the case that we're imagining
it only being deployed in Palo Alto
right lots of these organizations are
hoping to train something here and then
deploy it much more broadly for example
in Africa and there are so many things
that are problematic about that even if
we weren't thinking about anything that
had to do with humans right the
temperature and amount of sunlight and
amount of humidity and the type of roads
and the type of things that like you
know everything about this environment
will
will affect the way a system that is
developed here based on data collected
here will work and systems will work
much less well when any of those things
change right so if you train a model on
data all gathered here and then hope to
deploy it somewhere very different there
is no reasonable expectation that you
should have that it should work very
well yeah and that's a that's a very
good point so we don't fully understand
which of all of these different sets of
things is primarily responsible if
anyone is primarily responsible for this
sort of behavior we're seeing right and
that seems pretty problematic right
because these different reasons for this
behavior would happen would suggest very
different interventions right at least
from my perspective right they would
perhaps recommend different types of
data collection or different types
different types of model selection yep
okay so more broadly I'm very interested
in understanding when and why machine
learning algorithms treat different
demographic groups differently and
whether it's possible to make them
robust to moderate demographic changes
right so taking something and training
yeah yes
better testing is okay so so the
question was how about better testing
that's certainly going to be one of the
things that we're going to need to do
and one of the one of the
recommendations I have for systems in
general right if you want if you want to
deploy a system in a given environment
you probably should have tested it in an
environment that is somewhat analogous
that is definitely something that one
should consider yeah yes
you promise underlying model being
operate in a framework which is
essentially a great family of algorithms
which gets tailored by the date of this
train into the system and so not only do
we not have control over the framework
itself whether or not we're doing it
right or not right because we match it
against an expected result so it's
really the input data and expected
result that and everything else is right
so so the comment so let me again
rephrase and see if you like the
rephrasing I use so if we posit that in
the world there are some set of machine
learning mechanisms right stochastic
gradient descent SVM's
a few other like really simple I get I
get
shaking heads but you know though five
yeah yeah but like there are like let's
imagine there are five or six
optimization methods that everyone's
agreed upon are like the only ones you
ever need and there are five or six
classes of models that are the only ones
you would ever need and then the
question is on what data will you train
these models with these optimization
procedures so as to get a model out
which does particularly well on a
particular task when data is generated
in some similar way to the data
that you actually train upon and that's
certainly one way to look at machine
learning and it's certainly the case
that if your input data does not match
the the environment in which your model
will be deployed you will be able to see
it say very little about how that system
will perform but even if it does match
reasonably well a lot of the
optimization procedures and models
people tend to use have some of this
problematic behavior which may or may
not be entirely explained by the
training data used right and I also I
also don't like to give up the agency of
people who are using these things they
have a lot of control over what they're
going to use what they're going to
optimize over and with what ok so you
know I've given lots of examples about
concerns of uses of machine learning
both due to different and worse
treatment of different groups and people
as well as the context and opacity of
the uses of those systems right so we've
sort of tacitly been bantering about a
couple of different things and I want to
be slightly more precise so when we say
machine learning systems are unfair what
people usually mean one of two things
right one of the things they might mean
is that the predictions have much higher
error rates on different demographic
groups which is to say we're seeing
images labeled gorilla at much higher
rates for certain demographic groups
than other demographic groups that's one
type of behavior that people often refer
to as unfair but it is not the only one
separately if you just think about the
set of predictions a machine learning
model is choosing amongst and you break
out the rates of those different
predictions that the models making by
different demographic groups the model
might be making no mistakes but might be
making predictions of those different
outcomes at very different rates so
different demographic groups right and I
think we really have to grapple with
whether that is something we want to
consider acceptable or unacceptable
behavior and it will depend on the
context yes yes so what I mean is take a
random sample of an example that the
model will be operating upon from two
different demographic groups right
random sample generated perhaps from
like the same data generating process as
as the model was trained upon and look
at the probability with which that
random example would be assigned 1 or 0
in a simple binary prediction case yes
right right right and I think that's
that's a good point that's that's like
yes that's absolutely a third a third a
third set of concerns which is to say
you know if we're imagining that we're
optimizing this model to maximize the
number of arrests that we make that lead
to eventual convictions right I'm just
hypothesizing something that someone
might want to maximize if one was
thinking about using a machine learning
system for for example predictive
policing right that is a is a very
explicit value choice right and that may
very well not be one that all
communities agree are the right ones I
do want to give you know at least a
small amount of voice to the idea that
some machine learning experts really
don't think that this is a concern right
in fact there are certain people in the
machine learning community both
practitioner
and academics who basically say okay
it's true machine learning systems may
have different rates of predictions may
have different error rates but they do
better than humans making those
decisions and I want to I want to be
clear that like the community is not at
like total consensus okay but my point
is we really need to think about
precisely how these algorithms are going
to be designed and used right that that
statement is an imprecise one right and
if if we're thinking about humans
interacting with these machine learning
systems to try to make various types of
decisions it's really important that we
think about precisely how that works
because humans behave in very unexpected
ways and it's not as though a human in a
given environment making a set of
choices when augmented with additional
helpful information or even unhelpful
information will always make better
choices that's not there there's not a
great deal of evidence of that in fact
there was lots of evidence to the
contrary right so if you have a judge
who's making choices about bail and you
give them some some some signal about
the people that are making judgments
about and that signal whether that
signal is useful or not they will behave
differently with that signal in hand
when they're making those choices right
and humans are just very
counterintuitive right judges are much
stricter right before lunch and so I
mean I get hangry it's fine but I'm also
not sending people to prison so maybe
that's okay
so I think we really have to think
carefully as was mentioned before about
piloting and very carefully testing any
model we design in as close to of an as
close to an environment as possible as
we are imagining it being deployed right
not just in a black box looking at like
some simple statistics but also like if
we're going to give judges some some
recidivism tool we have to think about
how they'll interact with it yeah
[Laughter]
right I think so the comment was one
about the people who are in general
developing technologies have often been
their own guinea pigs which seems
somewhat more just than requiring
someone else to be the guinea pig for
something you've developed which you may
or may not understand or have complete
faith in its veracity I think that's an
interesting comment part of the concern
with any of these things is that they're
making high-stakes decisions that aren't
so clear how to do that with right so
most of the people who are building AI
systems aren't likely to be involved in
low-level criminal conviction cases
right I'm not saying that they shouldn't
be I'm just saying statistically
speaking that's not something that they
regularly interact with right you can
give anyone a disease it's pretty hard
to like place someone in a criminal
justice
and try to get you know yes that's right
very very little of the most popular
pieces of machine learning in both
industry and academia do much of any
reasoning about causality in any real
way right so the real question is are
the set of trends that these models are
predicting are they causal is the fact
that you know right sososo causality
hands raised if people know what
causality is okay so in general this
idea that like does the thing we're
looking at to try to predict whether
someone will commit a crime if I let
them out is that merely a statistical
pattern or is it the fact that I see
these certain behaviors in their history
and that in fact causes them to be more
likely not just happens to co-occur with
with a recidivism rates for example yeah
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
right so so we're we're poking at a few
different things here right this comment
was that you know I I've been very loose
with my words in terms of I I've been
using trend
I'm not explicitly trying to say
anything temporal with with that phrase
although it is the case that if we're
imagining deploying a system when things
change its behavior will change too or
at least its efficacy is likely to
change right so the example given that
like if you design a trading system
based on certain historical trends it
may make you a bunch of money for a
little while but it is unlikely to make
you a lot of money for very long yeah
yeah that's that's an interesting
comment yeah in the real world yeah so
the so the question being who designs
these things and that's one of the
things that's very interesting
there's simultaneously a big push for
what people call the democratization of
AI which is to say making it as easy as
possible for as many people as possible
to train models on any data set they
might have and while I am sympathetic to
the idea that
we should try to make the tools we're
developing accessible to lots of people
and train people how to use them
allowing people who know little to
nothing about statistics and little to
nothing about the consequences of the
prediction tasks they're training a
model to do or the historical context is
hugely problematic right and many of the
people in the real world there there are
people who like are using pie charts
packages that like maybe took undergrad
computer science classes and maybe took
some statistics classes but like are in
no way equipped to be making some of the
value judgments in terms of trade-offs
of what objective function they're
actually optimizing or anything else
they're just doing something which seems
to work better than you know some basic
if then else that they could program
without looking at historical data and
there are very few rules and regulations
as to who would be making such choices
there are a few exceptions right but yes
I know about validation no no no I I
wouldn't rather not talk about it yes so
so you know I I've said ok I'm happy to
talk about validation sure sure well I
mean right in general if people design
some machine learning system and train
it on some data there's a big concern
that you've overfit to your data and one
of the many methods for trying to
prevent and mitigate that is checking
how well your model works on data it did
not see in training ok they have what
they who is they and what do you mean by
half-jew this is another example of good
testing but it is not something that is
strictly necessary in the sense that
like there's no button which you have to
like prove in any meaningful way that
you've actually done meaningful
validation of whatever your whatever
you're thinking of deploying yes
the new one or the old one the new one
yeah right right I and I'm right I agree
that validation is regularly avoided in
all sorts of human based systems and I
think something that a lot of these a
lot of these comments are pointing
towards is a question of what we're
assuming algorithms will do that humans
cannot or do not right are we assuming
that algorithms are going to be making
better choices in humans are we assuming
the people who are generating and
designing these algorithms are going to
do more careful testing than humans or
human based systems and I don't have
good answers to those questions right
but I can say that one of at least there
are at least two concerns which I think
are very important to point out when
we're talking about decisions made by
one or very small number of machine
learning models when compared to humans
making the same sorts of choices even if
they faced similar biases right so
something that's pretty fascinating is
the extent to which humans do not like
to question the choices and predictions
made by machines I again this is some
really strange psychological feature of
humans we're much more likely to
question one another and the decisions
one another make then humans writ large
are willing to believe that a prediction
a Hugh tur makes even though it could be
simulating something much much worse
right then then the human making the
same sorts of choices and so that draws
a lot of concerns right in the case in
in all of these examples of criminal
justice reform using machine learning
models it may very well be the case
the judge would have made the right
choice but the judge gives a lot of
deference to the models that are being
provided to to the judge that's right
humans humans humans are absolutely
absolutely so right it's that okay yeah
so so the comment was that to entirely
encapsulate what's happening with the
machine learning method it's sufficient
to know the model the algorithm the
training data and the inputs for this
for this decision I would push back a
little bit in that there's a lot of
stochasticity and in a lot of these
algorithms so you know it won't make the
same deterministic choice given the same
exact data right so many of the you know
I I do want to push back on that to
begin with and second of all while it's
the case that humans have like many more
inputs than we can possibly model that
actually points to two the second thing
which I I think is important which is
that the extent to which we think you
know some humans may have mistakes may
make mistakes may be much more harsh
before lunch may be racist may be sexist
may be any number of other things but
they are limited in the extension rate
to which they themselves can make
decisions in any particular circumstance
right so like you are hungry before
lunch and then you go eat lunch and then
when you come back from lunch you're
being you know more lenient right which
is to say the people before lunch
definitely got hosed but the people
after lunch are perhaps getting some
better treatment and a machine learning
model may have much more uniform answers
which could be a good thing but could
also be problematic right if you're
someone who belongs to a class of people
who were historically denied home loans
if those choices were being made in a
non formulaic way by a collection of
bank employees and
of them were racist or sexist you could
go to a different bank I'm not saying
that that would have been a solution in
a lot of cases historically right in a
lot of cases there were formulae which
were explicitly trying to exclude large
fractions of the population from getting
home loans but if we imagine we're in a
world today and we you know there are
some people who are making bad choices
there are other there are other people
who can make different choices right
whereas if there is sort of one
foundational data set and a small number
of models trained on that data set
making all of these choices you don't
really have an alternative or a
competitor to turn towards ok ok so I
think it's important to think about any
tool which uses historical data this is
what I'm sort of sick calling a machine
learning algorithm to predict explain or
make decisions so it's really really
really crucial that we think about the
data we are training on right we've all
been alluding to this and poking at it
in various ways but this is not
something in many cases that people
think all that much about it's like oh
well we we all of this data was
available on Flickr so we gathered a
bunch of the data on Flickr and then we
see it kind of works in some other
environment not just like examples that
are that are gathered from Flickr but I
think it's really critical that we think
about well if we use loan repayment
rates for different populations as input
to our choices for who to give loans
today there are a huge number of
historical concerns that come from that
ok so I want to again just make some
brief comment about the extent to which
anything in our legal system may be able
to be used to address some of the
behaviors of machine learning systems as
they pertain to varying based on gender
race other protected attributes and the
short answer is this will probably not
be an easy solution
as we are all aware the legal system is
has a very difficult time figuring out
what to do with systems that don't have
agency to begin with right so so much of
of case law depends upon intent and it's
very hard to say who has what kind of
intent when you have a very complex
system such as some company training
some very complex model on some
large-scale data set right it's not
clear who had intent and who's
ultimately responsible for some of those
things there are a few exceptions right
so I've been poking a lot at two of them
that we may actually have some hope that
the law would have something to say
housing lending employment and the
criminal justice system are examples
where the law may have something to say
even if there's no intent and even if we
don't get to know a huge amount about
the process by which those decisions are
being made those are all cases in which
input-output pairs and distributions of
those and statistics about those may be
sufficient to argue that a machine
learning method is doing something which
may not stand up to to legal challenge
but most of the other settings where
we're thinking about this medicine or
many other things the the law will have
very little to say unless we have a lot
more information about models yes about
self-driving cars yeah yeah right and
this is yep yep who is jaywalking shame
on her she deserves to be
absurd right so there's yes so there's
there's definitely there's I I'm not a
legal scholar let me be perfectly clear
nowhere close to it
I know next to nothing about what the
law can do will do may do in these
contexts it's definitely interesting to
understand when a human is interacting
with a system that often does the right
thing but sometimes does not whether the
human who's ultimately supposed to be
the backup is liable when the system
fails right and this is the example
where a mostly autonomous car which was
supposed to have a backup human driver
when that runs over and kills a woman
who's responsible and and it's that is
not established law this is the first
example of one of these things and we
it's going to be very the process of
determining who's liable is going to be
contentious and with that actually I so
I'm going to say one or two more things
and then I actually want to talk about
one specific provocative example so as
we're sort of suggesting not all
mistakes of a machine learning system
are created equal again going back to
this question of what are we optimizing
right average zero one loss is probably
not what we're trying to optimize in
almost any context we've been discussing
false positives are relatively cost less
when we're thinking about self-driving
cars if we're talking about a positive
label as is there a human should I stop
whereas false negatives cause people to
be killed so it's really important to
think about sort of the cost of
different types of mistakes I don't want
to suggest that we should try to avoid
using machine learning in any
it's possible but that it's important
that we really grapple with these
socio-technical things as well as the
technical concerns that come from
machine learning you know there's lots
of fun and cool research questions in
this space so I want to hold on one
moment
oh this works excellent I just updated
my my software so I didn't know if this
is going to work okay so the thing I
want to talk to you about you know we
only we only have you know 15-20 minutes
left
this these slides if I were talking by
myself would not take 15 or 20 minutes
to go through but I would imagine
interaction from you guys will probably
make this take at least 15 or 20 minutes
but I'll just stop when we're out of
time so the one thing I want to tell you
a little bit about which is like an
active piece of my personal research is
is very very new just posted it to
archive Thursday which is joint with Ben
Wilson who's an excellent student at
Georgia Tech and Judy Hoffman will be
starting as faculty at Georgia Tech in
the fall and she did her PhD just across
the bay so and I'm very excited to hear
more about what all of you think about
this so with that caveat those caveats
okay so what I want to talk to you about
briefly which we've been talking talking
around a little bit is this idea of
using machine learning systems to do
driving centric object detection right
which is to say if you the the simplest
the the wild simplification of this task
is that we have a bunch of static images
taken from the vantage point of a car or
a self-driving car or something like
this and the machine learning task that
we're trying to accomplish is to draw a
bounding boxes around other cars around
bicycles around riders of those bicycles
around pedestrians around stop signs
around stoplights and then label them as
such
okay so this is like a pretty
well-formed computer vision task right
if this is like if the inputs are these
and and this is the the objective of
some system right I'll give you an
example here right so you know here's an
example of an image taken from the
vantage point of a car as well as being
you know draw sort of partitioning the
space into different objects that are
important for thinking about driving and
being labeled as you know cars
motorcycles riders stoplights things
like that
so this is a pretty standard vision task
at this point if you're talking about
like academic research in the vision
community and I started with a
hypothesis which was based on other
evidence I'd seen in other vision
domains which was that we would expect
to see error rates of systems of this
variety very systematically across skin
tones right so I alluded at the
beginning and talk briefly about
Amazon's facial recognition system
having lots of false positives when run
on run on Congress pictures and that
those were much more common amongst
amongst people of color and I also
mentioned right this example of Google
tagging facial images of
african-americans as gorillas actually
funny funny side story not funny but
Google for a time was just entirely
removing the tagged gorilla from their
image labeling as opposed to like trying
to fundamentally understand why their
system was doing that and trying to
change it this is like the min edit
distance thing yeah that's right
but it doesn't mean they understood why
it was happening and had a meaningful
fix that may not be true anymore but
that was true up to maybe two years
after this discovery and there's also
work that has shown that several
commercially available pieces of
software based on facial recognition are
much more likely to correctly classify
face
is to the correct gender for lighter
skinned men than darker skinned women
all right so we have a bunch of examples
specifically in the context of computer
vision systems relatively simple
supervised tasks where computer vision
systems seem to work better on lighter
skinned individuals so for this reason I
had this hypothesis yeah so well right
so there's definitely a question of
whether we should be doing facial
recognition on two-dimensional model on
two-dimensional representations of faces
at all we have a lot of evidence that it
doesn't work particularly well in
certain contexts and it works worse for
some demographic groups than others and
yet this is still something that Amazon
is actively selling to law enforcement
agencies so you can argue that it's a
good thing to do or a bad thing to do
but it is something people are doing
which is yes yeah okay
well I have to tell you a little bit
more about what I how we were going to
do this right so I wanted to know how we
can test this and I really wanted to ask
this on common classes of models used
for this in academia and common data
sets that are considered in in academia
which are generally used for this
driving centric object detection okay so
if you're someone who knows what these
are that's great if you don't that's
fine too these are just the first things
are classes of models that are generally
used for driving centric object
detection and like current computer
vision papers being published the next
two things the first one is a driving
centric object data set the other ones
just a more general-purpose
image recognition data set okay
okay lots of other details right so this
data set and most data sets don't
actually explicitly have demographic
tagging in them so we had to do a bunch
of things to actually have some of that
information to even be able to test this
hypothesis right so the experiment was
to fix a class of models and
optimization method a training data set
all of which are pretty standard in this
domain and measures of performance which
are common and common to evaluate the
veracity of how well computer vision
system is working broken out by a
specific notion of skin type okay
so I'll give you a few images these are
not meant to give you any meaningful
information other than you know these
are just bounding boxes we've drawn
around pedestrians you know there there
are some funny things there's a false
positive up here where the Podesta
this the system thinks this 30 foot
blow-up rat is a pedestrian
so in short there is likely to be some
difference in this very specific context
right so it appears that there is some
gap in terms of the average precision
and the finer grained
ap 75 measures these are just specific
measures that people do when trying to
understand how well these sorts of
bounding box problems are operating
where we see that the lighter skinned
pedestrians both in terms of AP and AP
75 the red lines are above the blue
lines which is to say the average
precision numbers are somewhat higher
for this very specific thing which I did
yeah
yeah yes so the the comment was it would
be very interesting to change the skin
tone of the pedestrians in some of our
examples and see what would happen my
guess is it would totally break and the
reason I say that is I don't know of a
way to do that where the examples would
look enough like the examples they were
trained upon and most of the vision
systems we're talking about these in
particular but the ones that are being
trained and our like state of the art in
general are very very very sensitive to
very small changes in in training data
or test data yeah absolutely no but I
agree that one of the interesting
questions is like the extent to which we
could try to understand when this will
and will not happen right and let me let
me be clear because I know many of you
are trained in a variety of different
things these are results that are
reported on validation right so we
trained on one dataset these are the
reports these are the results we found
on validation for this very particular
data set and these are not I have no
error bars here which pains me very
deeply right I don't say that like you
know with probably with 95% confidence I
see this gap this gap is one standard
deviation away from what you might
expect if they were equal the reason I
still think it's important and critical
to point this out as a possible problem
even though we don't have statistical
significance is the fact that in order
to have statistical significance for a
gap of say five to ten percent
difference in average precision we would
need roughly 15,000 images does someone
have $100,000 they'd like to give me
because I would be happy to gather that
data set right and I I think the onus is
really upon people who are planning to
make millions and millions and millions
of dollars off of these things to invest
some in an independent third party to
carefully evaluate how well the models
are going to work yeah
no no it's a much more fine-grained
version so so average precision looks at
the intersection over the union of the
the area of these bounding boxes there's
a ground truth bounding box there's the
box you drew it's certainly a
particularly bad error if there was a
bounding box and you didn't draw one or
there wasn't a bounding box and you drew
one but in general what's interesting is
how much space do they overlap upon and
this is some complex blend of several
different ways to look at those numbers
right so this is not saying that like
out of a hundred lighter-skinned
pedestrians we would see X and out of a
hundred darker-skinned pedestrians we
would see X minus five it's saying
something more precise than that and
more about like small differences in
terms of how well we drop bounding boxes
okay I mean it's right yes or no is not
the only answer that matters we're yeah
yeah so um you know if you if you prefer
numbers that are drawn like this rather
than then charts these are just what the
difference is
after some large number of training
grounds ends up looking like training
iterations looks like so as I mentioned
right AP and AP 75 which are the least
and most fine-grained in terms of
localization of these three metrics seem
to have some reasonably sized gaps in
terms of the percentage of of these
metrics when you look at light skin
versus darker skin pedestrians and again
these are not error bars these are just
the particular algorithms that are used
to train these models at randomized so
you have to imagine training them
several times and seeing sort of what
you might expect that gap to look like
as you train them multiple times okay so
a natural question one might ask
and i think i'll yes i'll finish right
on time is why we might expect this to
be happening right and if you talk to
it's really actually quite fascinating
the extent to which people have like
different opinions about why this might
be happening and as i mentioned right
we're not saying anything with like high
degrees of statistical power here so i'm
not saying that like i know or don't
know these things but i do have some
preliminary evidence that may suggest
what may or may not be at least
partially responsible okay so one of the
first things that you or anyone who
thinks about vision might think about is
that contrast is incredibly contrast
between the thing you're trying to draw
a bounding box around and the color of
the background that they are on is
incredibly important and makes you know
if there's less contrast it's a harder
task to draw an accurate bounding box
around a subject so one thing that we
did was we removed all nighttime images
and only looked at daylight and we still
saw this behavior right so it doesn't
seem that like the problems come from
nighttime images where there's much less
contrast between darker skinned
individuals and their surroundings
another general thing that makes vision
tasks harder is when there are lots and
lots of images all on top of each other
one of the example images I had there
within Time Square and they were like
lots and lots of people all on top of
each other and that's just it's harder
for humans to write it's not super easy
to draw a really precise boxes when
there are lots and lots of subjects of
your of your image but this gap seems to
persist even if we remove all of the
occluded occlusion is just the word for
this right
if you remove all of the occluded
individuals from your data set right and
it you could imagine again that like
maybe all of the people of a certain
demographic group live in very occluded
neighborhoods I'm not saying this is the
case but like people might argue that
this was the case and this does not seem
to be primarily the the source of this
behavior we people may separately wonder
right like what's the gap in terms of
how many lighter versus darker skinned
pedestrians are in the training set and
the answer is it's somewhere between 3 &
4 to
right because this particular dataset
which was collected by researchers at
Berkley was collected in the Bay Area
common New York comma Tel Aviv maybe one
or two other one or two other places but
they were not primarily gathered in for
example Atlanta right and so three three
or four to one is pretty representative
compared to a lot of that data sets we
have just in general right but it is not
particularly balanced in some other
senses okay so you might ask whether
we're sort of just not given enough data
to do particularly well in terms of the
smaller population and I I have again
limited information and limited
understanding but it does not appear to
me that we are primarily just like
running into not being able to do any
better on the smaller set okay so you
know I'm not trying to say that
self-driving cars are much more likely
to harm certain people than others that
is the sensational hot take of this
particular work but I am saying this
kind of vision system when trained on
publicly available data sets as opposed
to the proprietary data sets that
self-driving cars are competing with one
another to collect may have better
performance on different on different
types of pedestrians and we really need
to understand this phenomenon better and
we need the resources given from people
who are really standing in a place to
make a lot of money from using these
kinds of systems to more carefully
evaluate both the industry standard and
the academic standard types of models
and data sets right and more broadly
right and this again goes back to
several comments that have been made
throughout this presentation it's very
important that we carefully very very
carefully painstakingly evaluate all
parts of our machine learning systems in
environments that are as close as
possible to those they will actually be
deployed in okay if we hope to
understand how well they will behave
I don't care
[Applause]